(Bop It noises)
(ominous music)
- From one to ten only?
- Six and a half on
the high Richter scale.
- I would give myself a six to seven on
the high rating scalability
of being stoned.
- I like to pride myself on
being a functional stoner.
People don't suspect the guy in the tie
to be completely blazed.
- I'll probably get a world record.
- (laughs) What is this?
- When I was a kid, I
actually beat Bop It.
I think you had to do
like 100 or 115 around.
I just practiced--
(music)
- [Voiceover] Hit it a little harder.
- Um, I think I bob it?
(Bop It music)
- First I was good at this as a--
(Bop It screams)
- Oh, that's distracting.
- Hey, I'm making a
beat, I can rap to this.
(Bop It noises)
(Bop It screams)
(Bop It beat)
♫ My name is Boyd Brickz
and I got my own toy.
♫ I'm playin' with it lookin'
at me sayin' oh boy. ♫
- Yup. Yup.
- Flip it. Pull it. Pull it. Flip it.
- What is this? What
are the loops and pulls?
How would you know what
a sound looks like?
You can't read sound.
- Flip it. Pull it. Flip it. (screams)
- Oh man.
- I hate it. I hate you, Bop It!
- This is a great game, Bop It.
You could play this while you're waiting
for a stew to finish.
- Flip it. Flip it. Flip it.
(Bop It screams)
- I think first thing in the morning
is probably the best
time to play this game,
so you're waking up your mind
and you're waking up your hands. (laughs)
- Bop It is a toy made so white people
won't kill other people.
- The Bop It sounds got recorded
when Bugs Bunny would fall down stairs.
- And then why the
creator of Bop It was like
that's a good idea to
put in a children's game,
a person shrieking after
being, I don't know, stabbed--
- A man had three pet
frogs and he caught 'em
and they all made different sounds,
and when they died he put
his ashes in this machine.
You're hearing dead frogs.
♫ It's a tragedy, it's a recipe,
♫ but who I am is what you see.
♫ We gonna hit these bops, boobity bops,
♫ as a matter of fact of
the school skitty scat. ♫